What's going to the dentist like?
It was actually a lot of fun.
The first time I went to My Kid's Dentist, it was a short visit.
I got to meet my dentist; she was super friendly.
My mom and dad were there with me...
...while the dentist looked in my mouth.
She counted my teeth and checked to make sure that all my teeth...
....were growing in the correct way.
She also looked to see if I had any cavities.
I saw all kinds of interesting things in the dentist's office.
Things like the exam chair, it goes up and down...
...so the dentist can see in your mouth.
There's a special light that's really bright...
...so the dentist can see all of your teeth.
And there are special tools like a little mirror,...
...and an x-ray machine that takes pictures of the insides of your teeth.
There's even a little hose to spray water into your mouth.
If I ever have any questions about my teeth...
...or how to take care of them, I just ask my dentist.
Your dentist is a friendly doctor who wants you to have healthy shiny teeth.